- [Narrator] OK, Cree,
whenever you're ready.
- I'll hug you and
squeeze you and kiss you
and put coins in your eyes.
That's why we gonna be
kids next door forever.
I am Kidagakash.
Welcome to the City of Atlantis.
Angelica, you know that
you're mean to those babies,
and I've had enough!
I will not let you bother
them again. (banner swishes)
- [Narrator] Works for me.
(energetic, percussive music)
(steady, percussive music)
This is Cree Summer, and her
voice is kind of legendary.
- I am best known for being
Penny from Inspector Gadget.
Follow them, Brain, they look suspicious.
Inspector Gadget, are you alright?
Susie Carmichael, who
really stood up to Angelica
and took care of those babies.
And I play Elmyra (sings off-key).
Princess Kida from the
lost city of Atlantis.
Loh-gee-goh-neh.
(laughs) There you go.
There's the taste of some
of my greatest hits. (claps)
- I knew Uncle Gadget
would never rob a bank.
- Let's see, I started voice
acting when I was 11 years old.
My father, Don Francks,
was the voice of Sabretooth
from the "X-Men."
He also was the very first
person to every voice Boba Fett
from "Star Wars," which
is such a cool-ass thing.
And he had already been
cast on "Inspector Gadget."
And he asked if they would
be kind enough to read his
daughter, and they said,
"Sure, we'll give her a shot".
And it literally took off
like wildfire from there.
- Hi, my name's Susie, what's yours?
- I know for Susie, one of
the most important things was
that she sound smart and
that she's very well spoken
because there were not a lot
of brown girls in cartoons.
As a matter of fact, there still aren't.
- [Narrator] Beyond all
this, Cree is unique
for another reason.
Historically, white voice
actors generally did the voices
for cartoon characters of all races.
Cree has thrived in space that
has often overlooked people
who look like her.
- Ow!
Come on in, boys.
I just put on some moth balls.
(playful string music)
(remote clicks)
- What if some talent agent
comes along and says I have--
- I mean, let's face it.
I do the voices of all the brown girls.
And all the animated brown girls ...
there still ain't that many
because there's this really
crazy belief that black girls
don't watch cartoons, and
that we don't collect comics,
and that we don't like
Sci-Fi, and that's B.S., man.
We love it.
I love when people of color
come up to me and say,
"You don't know what it
meant to me to see myself
in a cartoon.
"I got one little black
girl that I get to see
that looks like me.
"Thank you so much."
I get off on that. It's great.
(icon dings)